on a Saturday morning yet isn't that
nice
thank you all and we're gonna have an
incredible convention it's really going
well we're gonna have an incredible
convention and we're gonna get things
solved and we're going to do lots of
wonderful things for our country most
importantly so I'm here today to
introduce the man who will be my partner
in this campaign and the White House to
fix our rigged system we are in a rigged
rigged system and to make America safe
again and to make America great again I
want to also address the Islamic terror
attack in France we've witnessed horror
beyond belief no matter where you look
and now it's happening more and more and
it's never going to stop we need new
leadership we need new thinking we need
strength we need in our country law and
order and if I'm elected president that
will happen
I want to express our unyielding support
for the people of France and we mourn
their loss as a nation and as far as
Turkey is concerned so many friends in
Turkey great people amazing people we
wish them well it looks like they're
resolving the difficulty but we wish
them well a lot of a lot of anguish last
night but hopefully it'll all work out
now as hopefully the next president of
the United States I want to refer back
to what's happened over the years the
Middle East today is more unstable than
ever before never been like this out of
control after four years of Clinton who
really led the way and let Obama down a
horrible path because I don't even think
he could have made these decisions so
badly she led him right down a horrible
path he didn't know what he was doing
Iraq Syria all into chaos and Iran is on
a path to nuclear weapons and on top of
that we gave them back 150 billion
dollars and we didn't get our hostages
until the end now we're seeing unrest in
Turkey a further demonstration of the
failures of Obama 10 you just have to
look every single thing they touched has
turned to horrible horrible
death-defying problems we also need to
bring back in this country because we
see what happened our industry our
manufacturing our jobs they've been
taken away like we're babies take it
away
and we're gonna bring them back I found
the leader who will help us deliver a
safe society and a prosperous really
prosperous society for all Americans
Indiana Governor Mike Pence was my first
choice I've admired the work he's done
especially in the state of Indiana and
I'm going to go over some of those
accomplishments in just a minute but I
also admire the fact that he fights for
the people and he's going to fight for
you he is a solid solid person
governor Pence served Indiana with
distinction in Congress he rose to
leadership and served as the chairman of
the entire House Republican Conference
number one he's really got the skills of
a highly talented executive leading the
state of Indiana
to jobs growth and opportunity in spite
of the relentless obstacles put in his
way and every States way by the Obama
administration it's horrible out there
high taxes and regulations and it's out
of control
Mike Pence is a man of honor character
and honesty we know that Hillary Clinton
is the embodiment of corruption she's a
corrupt person what she's done with her
emails what she's done with so many
things and I see the ads up all the time
the ads
she's totally bought and paid for by
Wall Street the special interests the
lobbyists 100%
she's crooked Hillary
and I think that well she got away with
murder in fact I think it might be her
greatest accomplishment escaping the
recent scandal and her lies and the loss
of 33,000 emails but it wasn't a loss
she discarded that in itself is a major
crime other people have been paying
tremendous prices for what they've done
which is peanuts compared to what
happened with Hillary Clinton 33,000
emails are missing and that's okay
didn't give them to the FBI didn't give
them to the Attorney General and that's
okay
wipes her server clean that's okay
these are crimes these are crimes and
how she got away with it I think I
understand it but I think a lot of
people don't but I do believe while she
didn't pay the price she should have
paid she's going to pay that price when
November 8 rolls around she's going to
pay at the polls I believe
on top of everything else hillary made
twenty one point six million dollars
giving speeches to special interests in
a short period of time
she's totally owned by Wall Street we
believe in Americanism she believes in
globalism and it's not that she believes
in it the people that give her all of
this money believe in it and she'll
believe in whatever they want her to
believe believe me that's it what a
different between crooked Hillary
Clinton and Mike Pence Mike Pence will
never be afraid to speak the name of our
enemy radical Islam radical Islamic
terrorism you saw it the other day with
the truck screaming out the window you
heard what he was screaming out the
window you saw it in San Bernardino you
saw it at the World Trade Center you saw
it in Orlando how horrible was that you
saw it in Paris you see it all over and
Hillary is a weak person we are the Law
& Order candidates and with a Law &
Order party we're going to change things
around there's going to be respect again
for law and order
Hillary Clinton's foreign policy helped
launch Isis you know she's talking I see
the ad she puts on if I make one
statement which is fine she'll take that
statement and put it on a totally
dishonest ed she's got a lot of money
because it's given to her by the
lobbyists and by the special interests
got a lot of money but I see the ads on
foreign policy she's talking about
Donald Trump doesn't have foreign policy
experience of course not I've been a
very very very successful business
person I mean but but if you look at my
calls I said don't go into Iraq nobody
cared because I was a business person I
was a civilian take the oil many many
calls I've made you take a look I said
that in Scotland and in the UK that was
going to happen I was the one that
predicted it and everybody said he's
wrong he's wrong
President Obama said if it happens
they're gonna get to the back of the
line which probably is one of the
reasons they lost of course I consider
it a win I think it was a win for them
actually because they don't want to be
told what to do and they don't want to
be told that when people pour into the
country they have to take them even if
they're not qualified even if they don't
have paperwork even if they have no idea
where they come from and I said that
Breck's it's going to happen
I said that they are going to break away
and everybody laughed at me and the odds
were 20% and then when it happened she
took an ad saying Oh Donald Trump said
this or that but I'm the one that said
it was going to happen and some of the
more fair reporters about 30% of them
said he was right I appreciate that 70
percent didn't so that's okay
so Mike Pence will never be afraid to
speak the name of our enemy so important
now I think if you look at one of the
big reasons that I chose Mike and one of
the reasons is party unity I have to be
honest so many people have said party
unity because I'm an outsider I want to
be an outsider I think it's one of the
reasons I won in landslides
when in the land sighs this wasn't close
now this wasn't close this was a letter
in the history of the Republican Party
history with seventeen people running
you have to understand other people ran
against one two and three with seventeen
we got I say we because I'm the
messenger I'm a messenger I'm doing a
good job but I'm a messenger we got
almost fourteen million votes that's
more than any other person in the
history of the Republican Party in the
primary system running for president
think of it
that's more than Ronald Reagan who we
love that's more than Richard Nixon it's
more than Dwight the Eisenhower you know
you won the second world war in all
fairness it's pretty good it's more than
the bushes but I mean by a lot I don't
mean by a little but that's what
seventeen people people don't over say
that that means our message is
unbelievable and I want to thank all of
the loyal people because I have such
loyal unbelievable people and they
displayed that just yesterday in
Cleveland well it's going to be so
amazing but they displayed it it was on
display where we had this group of
people who many of whom I've known and I
won't say because for party unity I'll
say they're wonderful people okay never
Trump they said never Trump never
trouble oh we're gonna win they got
crushed and they got crushed immediately
because people want what we're saying to
happen they're tired of a country that
has horrible trade deals that has no
borders that has taxes that are through
the roof highest taxed nation just about
in the world that has regulations that
don't allow you to start a business and
destroy your business if you do start
and by the way speaking of destroying
businesses we're gonna take care of the
miners and we're gonna take care of the
steel workers we're gonna put them back
to work
so they're very tired of it but I want
to thank all of those people that
delegates that were on the different
committees because boy wood was that
something did we show them something
and unfortunately the vote was very late
but essentially we had a hundred and
twelve to twelve this was the vote that
was going to put it on to the floor and
we're gonna have a big fight not gonna
have a fight people agree with what we
they want the wall they want the borders
they want these things to happen and
what we're doing and what we're doing
that I'm so proud of sopra and nobody
else would even think about doing it
I've fought very hard for it we'll call
it the Johnson amendment where he took
away from the evangelicals and I want to
thank the evangelicals because without
the evangelicals I could not have won
this nomination the evangelicals have
been unbelievable I dominated with the
evangelicals a lot of people were
surprised they say he's not perfect but
you know what they know I'm gonna get
the job done and they're really smart
and I said and I said for the
evangelicals that we're gonna do
something that nobody's even tried to do
you have the Johnson amendment passed by
Lyndon Johnson and his group and he was
a powerful president he knew how to get
things done he got bogged down in a war
that was a disaster and it destroyed him
but he was a powerful president and we
call it the Johnson amendment where you
are just absolutely shunned if you're
evangelical if you want to talk religion
you lose your tax-exempt status we put
into the platform we're gonna get rid of
that horrible Johnson amendment and
we're gonna let evangelicals we're gonna
let Christians and Jews and people of
religion talk without being afraid to
talk I saw this I had so many great
leaders so many times up to my office
the top the absolute top evangelical
leaders Christian leaders Jewish leaders
believe it or not some Muslim leaders
people gonna be surprised to hear that I
had the top leaders up to my office and
I said why is it that you're so powerful
as an individual and yet when you get
out there you're sort of timid and they
didn't know how to answer the question
and it took two or three meetings before
I figured it out one great great
gentleman that everybody knows but whose
name I will not reveal said mr. Trump we
live in fear in our churches and our
synagogues we live in fear that we're
going to lose our tax-exempt status if
we say anything that's even slightly
political and I looked out the window I
was in Trump Tower and I pointed to
people walking down the street I said
well they have the right to speak but
you don't that means they're more
powerful than you are we have to do
something about it how did it start how
did it start
and they said it started because of
Lyndon Johnson and he actually had a
problem in Texas with a certain
religious leader and he did this and he
got it done and we're gonna undo it so
that religious leaders in this country
and those unbelievable people and not
because they backed me at such large
numbers but so that religion can again
have a voice because religions voice has
been taken away and we're gonna change
that okay all right back to Mike Pence
so one of the primary reasons I chose
Mike was I looked at Indiana and I won
Indiana big remember Indiana was gonna
be the firewall that's where Trump was
going down they agreed at Wynn New York
I'd win Pennsylvania win all this place
but Indiana was gonna be the firewall so
I got to study Indiana and I got to
study in New York and a lot of other
places and I saw how NAFTA signed by
Bill Clinton has drained our
manufacturing jobs just drained us like
we've never been drained before NAFTA
again signed by Bill Clinton NAFTA is
the worst economic deal in the history
of our country manufacturing down in
some states 55 60 % it's a horror show
moving to Mexico moving to other places
I have a friend who's a great builder
what he builds his plants it's only does
this bill plants he doesn't build
buildings he doesn't but he builds
plants it's the biggest in the world
from what I hear I said how's business I
was with him the other day how's
business
it goes unbelievable I said really well
I'm surprised why is it unbelievable
because I think of him his building in
this country he said Donald what we're
doing in Mexico you won't believe so
what do you mean he said we're building
plants in Mexico the likes of which
we've never seen I said what about this
country not much not much that's the
expression he said exactly that
not much
I said but Mexico he said you've never
seen anything like it
it's incredible folks that's gonna stop
we're gonna go reverse it we're gonna
bring our jobs back to this country we
can't be the stupid people anymore okay
and he was better than a pollster he's
better than a consultant I'll say how
are we doing and you get a big report
that costs you millions of dollars does
it cost me minutes me I give him $10,000
okay of course other people millions
cost other campaigns millions to get a
report every time they get a report it's
Millions but I'll tell you what a guy
like this is better than anybody you can
hire to do a report and he said it he
didn't say it from the standpoint of
he's upset about it just fact how we
doing unbelievable in Mexico fact he
actually said I've never ever seen
anything like it and if you look for it
is building massive plants there instead
of Michigan we want him to build them in
Michigan they're gonna build them in
Michigan and you know that I know how to
do that so easy so easy but they're not
going to do and they're not going to
take advantage of us without retribution
there are consequences when you fire
thousands of people and move to another
country and then think you're going to
make your product and sell it in here
there are consequences and those
consequences are going to keep companies
in our country it's very simple and
everybody here knows what the
consequences are but I won't say that
because I'm much more interested right
now in Mike
Indiana's unemployment rate and this is
the primary reason I wanted my other
than he looks very good other than he's
got an incredible family incredible wife
and family Karen is crazy
credible food highly respected expected
to go for another four years he would
have one I think very easily in Indiana
Indiana their unemployment rate has
fallen when he was there when he started
at eight point four percent when he was
governor and when he took over - less
than five percent in May of 2016
since January 2013 Indiana's labor force
has increased by more than 186 thousand
jobs you have to understand I've gone
around to all these states I've gone to
all of them and every time I have
statisticians I say give me the status
on the state and it's always bad down
down down down 40% 50% 60% in some cases
here's somebody where it's gone up
private-sector job growth is up by more
than one hundred and forty seven
thousand jobs since 2013 that's like
very unusual governor Pence balanced the
budget can you imagine a balanced budget
our budget so out of whack in this
country we don't know what we're doing
we're gonna very soon 21 trillion
dollars he balanced the budget they
don't know what that means
governor pence balanced the budget
produced a surplus and maintains a two
billion dollar reserve fund in the state
of Indiana it's also rated triple-a
their bonds are rated triple-a very few
states have to triple-a the best that's
as good as you can get whether you're a
company it's a triple-a Indiana was
recently recognized by chief executive
magazine as the number one state in the
Midwest for business number one and it's
not even close there are approximately
34,000 fewer Hoosiers on unemployment
insurance now than they were when Mike
Pence took office so you have fewer
Hoosiers fewer people from Indiana
besides that Bobby Knight my friend who
really did help me I mean if you want a
reference Bobby Knight in Indiana we
love Bobby Knight but he agrees with
everything I'm saying he loves the
governor Indiana has the second lowest
unemployment rate in the nation for
veterans where nobody's fighting for the
veterans like I'm fighting for the
veterans the veterans have been left
behind if you remember a few months ago
Hillary Clinton said that really they're
doing much better the VA is much better
they're doing a much better job than
people give it credit for people are
dying online waiting four five six days
for doctors people are dying on they
can't even see a doctor it's a scandal
take a look at what's happening with the
VA in Arizona take a look at what's
happening with what you know just the
Veterans Administration in hospitals
it's a scandal it's corrupt
it's incompetent it's a scandal and
Hillary Clinton thought it was just fine
and boy am I gonna win big with the
veterans I mean we know that for a fact
so it's now 2.4% for veterans in 2013
when Mike Pence took office the rate for
veterans was 6.7 it was 31st in the
nation one of the bad ones and now it's
almost the best got him jobs got him
jobs Indianapolis is ranked second in
top ten metro areas for young college
graduates that's a great thing they're
gonna stay there that's a great thing
and Mike worked hard on that he was
telling me that was not easy under
governor Pence's leadership Indiana
enacted the largest k-12 education
funding increase in the state's history
so you're balancing budgets and yet
you're giving more money to education
it's not a great thing
Indiana has just about the largest
school choice program in America school
choice is where it's at folks you want
to get your schools better you've got to
get rid of Common Core fast governor
Pence enacted the largest income tax cut
in the state's history think of that
we're cutting taxes and balancing
budgets and along with corporate tax
reform just about number one in the
country CNBC ranked Indiana first in the
nation for its infrastructure so with
all of these cuts and all of these
balancing budgets were spending more
money on education and the
infrastructure is kept up that had so
much look as a builder nobody in the
history of this country has ever known
so much about infrastructure is Donald
Trump I build infrastructure do I know
how to build a wall do I know how to
build infrastructure you know it's very
interesting we're building we're
building i won the which is pretty
amazing in the Obama administration but
I won the right to have the old post
office building on Pennsylvania Avenue
right near the White House and it's an
amazing probably the best location what
are the most sought after projects in
the history of the GSA
General Services and I really like
what's happened we're gonna have an
opening very soon Ivanka and Eric and
Don did a fantastic job on it but I
thought the other day I was going over
the numbers we were under budget and
about a year actually more than a year
but were a year ahead of schedule and
were under budget substantially and the
quality of the work is even better than
we originally were going to do and when
I explain to a government
representatives that we're under budget
and ahead of schedule they almost fell
off because they'd never heard those
words before they've never so when I see
what happened to Indiana which was
having tremendous problems when I see
what happened
to Indiana under Mike's work also his
predecessor did a great job by the way
great job who's now a Duke who's now at
Purdue when I see what happened with
respect to the numbers the state and
everything else that to me was probably
the single most important point because
it's something that hasn't happened
almost has not happened in this whole
country the turnaround and the strength
of Indiana has been incredible and I
learned that when I campaigned there and
I learned that when I won that state in
a landslide and I learned that when
governor Pence under tremendous pressure
from establishment people endorse
somebody else but it was more of an
endorsement for me if you remember he
talked about Trump then he talked about
Ted who's a good guy by the way who's
but going to be speaking at the
convention Ted Cruz good guy but he
talked about Trump Ted then he went back
to Trump I said who did he into us so
even though he was under pressure
because I'm so on you know outside of
the establishment it was the single
greatest non endorsement they've ever
had him
okay I will tell so with that I would
like to introduce a man who I truly
believe will be outstanding in every way
and will be the next vice president of
the United States Governor Mike Pence
thank you thank you everybody thank you
on behalf of my family here and looking
on would you join me in thanking Donald
Trump Melania and his entire family for
the sacrifices that they are making to
make America great again
and I thank Donald Trump for the
confidence you've placed in us and I
accept your invitation to run and serve
as vice president of the United States
of America you know I come to this
moment deeply humbled but with a
grateful heart grateful to God for His
amazing grace grateful to my wonderful
wife Karen and our three incredible kids
Michael Charlotte and Audrey and
grateful to this builder this fighter
this patriotic American who has set
aside a legendary career in business to
build a stronger America Donald J Trump
and let me say having had the privilege
to spend time with this man and his
family out of the limelight I know what
all of America will soon know even
better these are good people
Donald Trump is a good man and he will
make a great president of the United
States of America Donald Trump
understands the frustrations and the
hopes of the American people like no
leader since Ronald Reagan the American
people are tired we're tired of being
told we're tired of being told that this
is as good as it gets
we're tired of having politicians in
both parties in Washington DC tell us
we'll get to those problems tomorrow and
as Ronald Reagan said we're tired of
being told that a little intellectual
elite in a far distant Capitol can plan
our lives better for us than we can plan
them for ourselves Donald Trump gets it
and he understands the American people
I truly am deeply humbled to be at his
side today and when I got this call last
Wednesday I could only think of that
ancient question Who am I Oh Lord and
who is my family that you have brought
us this far so let me try and answer
that question for a few minutes now
people who know me well know I'm a
pretty basic guy I'm a Christian a
conservative and a Republican in that
order and while I'm currently I
currently have the privilege of serving
the state that I love I'm really I'm
really just a small-town boy who grew up
in southern Indiana with a big family
and a cornfield in the backyard like
Donald Trump my grandfather immigrated
to this country and in many ways I grew
up with a front row seat to the American
dream I watched my mom and dad build
everything that matters a family a
business and a good name the heroes in
my youth were John F Kennedy and the
Reverend dr. Martin Luther King jr. I
actually started in politics in the
other party but when I came of age I was
inspired by the ideals and the eloquence
of our 40th president and I became a
Republican most important thing in my
life was at 31 years ago I married the
girl of my dreams Karen pence who will
make a great second lady of the United
States of America
and while this office is an
extraordinary office to which to aspire
the highest role I will ever play is
d-a-d and I'm a proud father of a
college student a graduate turned writer
and a United States Marine
you know my career I ran for Congress
before the Republican revolution led by
Newt Gingrich in 1994 I wasn't
successful by the time I got elected to
Washington DC sometimes I felt like I
was elected after it was over from
almost my first day in Congress I found
myself battling the big spenders in both
political parties whether opposing No
Child Left Behind the prescription
entitlement or the Wall Street bailout
bailout I fought every single day for
taxpayers and fiscal responsibility when
I was a member of the Congress of the
United States and after the Republicans
lost the Congress in 2006 I was actually
unanimously elected to serve in
leadership and we fought back against
the Nancy Pelosi Congress we opposed
Obamacare we opposed their tax increases
we opposed their cap-and-trade and I was
part of the team that won the Congress
back from Democrat control in 2010 and
all that happened before I went back
home again to Indiana but I want to say
I answered this call for two reasons
first because I know from firsthand
experience that strong Republican
leadership can bring about real change
just like we've seen in the Hoosier
State and secondly because Hillary
Clinton must never become president of
the United States of America
on the first point I know what I'm
talking about you know in Indiana we
prove every day you can build a growing
economy on balanced budgets low taxes
even while making record investments in
education roads and health care we like
to say Indiana's a state that works and
it does Indiana works because Republican
principles work every time you put them
into practice today we have a two
billion dollar surplus and the highest
credit rating in the nation and since I
became governor Hoosier businesses large
and small have created nearly a hundred
and fifty thousand net new jobs and we
have more Hoosiers going to work than
ever before in the 200 year history of
the great state of Indiana
that's what Republican leadership gets
you and let me say from my heart that's
what the no-nonsense leadership of
Donald J Trump will bring to Washington
DC but elections are about choices
elections are about choices and I also
join this ticket because the choice
could not be more clear the stakes could
not be higher Americans can choose a
leader who will fight to make America
safe and prosperous again and bring real
change or we can elect someone who
literally personifies the failed
establishment in Washington DC seven and
a half years of Barack Obama and Hillary
Clinton's policies have weakened
America's place in the world and stifled
our nation's economy terrorist attacks
at home and abroad the grim and
heartbreaking scenes from France just a
few short days ago the attempted coup in
Turkey all attest to a world spinning
apart history teaches us that weakness
arouses evil Hillary Clinton and Barack
Obama's foreign policy of leading from
behind moving red lines feigning resets
with a resurgent Russia and the rise of
Isis is a testament to this truth of
history and we must bring a change to
America's stand in the world we cannot
have four more years apologizing to our
enemies and abandoning our friends
America needs to be strong for the world
to be safe on the world stage Donald
Trump will lead from strength he will
rebuild the arsenal of democracy stand
with our our allies and hunt down and
destroy the enemies of our freedom and
at home and at home the choice is just
as clear where Donald Trump wants to cut
taxes Hillary Clinton plans to raise
taxes on working families small
businesses and family farms where Donald
Trump is committed to repeal Obamacare
lock stock and barrel
Hillary Clinton looks at Obamacare as a
good start and wants to take Bernie
Sanders path down to single-payer
socialized medicine where Donald Trump
supports an all-of-the-above strategy
and will end the war on coal Hillary
Clinton actually promised an energy plan
that would close American coal mines and
put coal miners out of work where Donald
Trump wants to build a wall and
temporarily suspend immigration from
countries compromised by terrorism
Hillary Clinton plans to ignore the
Supreme Court reimpose executive amnesty
and would increase increase our refugee
program by more than 500% and where
Donald Trump will appoint justices like
the late Antonin Scalia who will uphold
our Constitution Hillary Clinton will
appoint Supreme Court justices who will
legislate from the bench abandon the
sanctity of life and rewrite our Second
Amendment to every American
who shares our convictions I say to you
join us for the sake of our security for
the sake of our prosperity for the sake
of a Supreme Court that will never turn
its back on our god-given liberties
let's come together as a party and a
people and a movement to make America
great again and that day begins when
Donald Trump becomes the 45th president
of the United States of America thank
you for the honor thank you for your
support and god bless the United States
of America